Na Klos, wie geht's? Scheiße. Irgendein Grund oder nur so zum Spaß? Gründe gibt's genug. Echt? Nenn mir einen. Wie's icke. Klimakatastrophe. Klimakatastrophe? Na ich sag lieber Klimawandel. Es ist alles eine Frage der Einstellung. Ich sag mal, die Mammut-Fellhändler haben das Ende der Eiszeit sich ja auch als Klimakatastrophe bezeichnet. Schwarzer gab's eben schon immer. Man muss Veränderungen als Chance begreifen. Als Chance zum Aussterben, so wie die Mammuts? Hm, vielleicht hast du recht. Quatschkopp, Mensch, der Klimawandel hat sogar positive Seiten, zumindest für uns hier in Deutschland. Oh Gott, erzähl mir jetzt nichts von schönen Sommern und der Ostseeküste gleich hinter Bernau. Ich hasse Strände, die hässlichen Menschen, die blöden Kinder, überall Sand und Algen. Und dann, wenn du gerade denkst, es könnte doch noch lustig werden, stellt sich heraus, dass sich da bloß ein Scherzbold, eine Plastaheifischflosse auf den Rücken gebunden hat. Ach, Klos, nun tu doch nicht so. Ich weiß doch genau, wie viel Spaß du an der Ostsee immer beim Sandburg zertreten hattest. Das war kein Spaß, das war eine azierische Maßnahme. Die Kleinen müssen lernen, dass die Welt grausam ist. Naja, jedenfalls musst du dir keine Sorgen machen. Bis Berlin wird die Ostsee wohl nicht kommen.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 75. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße euch am 16. Februar 2008. Der Tag, der mich nach Hamburg geführt hat, das schöne Hamburg. Ich bin mal gerade wieder dabei, eine kleine Podcastreise zu übernehmen, diesmal nicht ganz so lang und ausufernd wie neulich, aber immerhin soll mich das hier durch zwei oder drei Sendungen führen. Jetzt bin ich gerade eingekehrt hier in einem gemütlichen, schicken, relativ neuen Haus und begrüße an meiner Seite den Ron. Hallo Ron.
Hallo, hallo.
Jetzt musst du Hallo sagen, genau, das hast du gut gemacht Ron. Ron, du bist ja nun auch schon seit Ewigkeiten beim CCC mit dabei, das muss am Anfang mal gesagt werden. Seit wann eigentlich? Wann bist du nur zum Chaos gestoßen?
Oh, das ist lange her. Ich habe zwischendurch mal versucht, eine Jahreszahl, wie viele Kongresse ich eigentlich schon gemacht habe und auf wie vielen Kongressen ich schon was erzählt habe.
Und?
Ich weiß nicht, über 15.
Über 15, aber wir haben doch schon, wie viel haben wir jetzt zusammen, 24?
Ja, auf den ersten paar war ich nicht da. So, und dann Eidlstedter Bürgerhaus natürlich und alles mitgenommen dann.
Und was hat dich eigentlich zum Club geführt?
Oh, wie so viele Leute nicht. Ich hatte irgendwie ein interessantes technisches Problem und dachte, ich muss mal mit Leuten sprechen, die besser sind als ich. Und dann schließt du im Club auf und stellst fest, da ist keiner besser als du. Es sind nur alle andere genauso gut bei anderen Dingen.
Das heißt, du hast dein eigentliches Problem, aber du hast immer keine Antwort gefunden.
Ich glaube damals nicht wirklich, aber das macht ja nichts, weil du triffst so viele Leute und stellst fest, wie viele andere lustige Probleme es gibt, zu denen es auch noch keine Antworten gibt. Ja, und andere Probleme zu gehen, zu Antworten gibt und wie man sich da gegenseitig befruchten kann.
Aber das war dann so, wir reden schon von 80er Jahren irgendwann, oder? Und später warst du dann auch eine Weile lang Sprecher und hast dann Stimme dem Club geliehen.
Genau, das waren sieben Jahre. Sieben Jahre mit Andi und dann später mit Frank Sprecher gemacht. Zwischendurch ein bisschen Vorstand natürlich.
War das lustig?
Ja, natürlich war das lustig. Wir haben ja da zwischendurch spannende Themen gehabt, wo wir auch richtig was reißen konnten. Also als es losging mit den 0-190ern und dem Missbrauchsszenario dort und so weiter. Also die Diskussionen, die es dort gab, das wurde ja auch im Fernsehen diskutiert, Gesprächsrunden und so weiter. Da waren wir glaube ich die Einzigen, die so ein bisschen Druck gemacht haben gegenüber der Post damals vielleicht noch. Oder schon gerade eben erst Telekom?
Das war dann schon Telekom, das war so Anfang der 90er, end 90, 92.
Ja, aber gerade eben erst. Dass man sich mal hinstellt und sagt, da gibt es also diverse Möglichkeiten, wie auch eine hohe Telefonrechnung zustande kommen kann, ohne dass jemand tatsächlich eine 090er Nummer gewählt hat. Und das gab schon ganz gut Gegenwind. Da konnten wir, glaube ich, einiges machen. Konnten die Presse gut unterstützen in der Darstellung, was alles schiefgehen kann und so. Das waren gute Diskussionen. Und die anderen Sachen, an was erinnere ich mich. Dann diese Geschichten. Das war lustig. Mit den Atomtests in Frankreich. Frankreich hat irgendwann wieder angefangen, Atomtests zu machen. Und dann war die Frage, was ist die angemessene Form der digitalen Demonstration? Und Internet hatte ja zwar schon eine Menge Leute, aber eigentlich kein Mensch. Und dann haben wir den Leuten versucht zu erklären, wie das ist, wenn man einfach Hotlines von französischen Firmen dichtmacht. Und vor allen Dingen nämlich 0-800er-Nummern. Oder wie hieß das damals, 0-130er-Nummern? Genau, 0-130er-Nummern und dann schöne Listen veröffentlicht von 0-130ern und wir wissen ja, dass dann der, der ans Telefon geht, zahlt die Rechnung. Und alle französischen, was man auch finden konnte. Und dann gab es ein paar Irre, die haben dann, weil die Menschheit hatte ja im Wesentlichen Modems, kein ISDN, kamen gerade so und so, Diler gebaut, die Bildschirmschonermäßig, immer wenn der Rechner sonst nichts zu tun hat, 0-130er von französischen Firmen gewählt haben.
Wir kommen natürlich total jetzt von unserem Thema ab, was wir eigentlich besprechen wollten. Aber ich finde das gerade noch ganz interessant, weil gerade diese Geschichte, das ist so eine der Sachen, die ich in Erinnerung habe, wo ich so im Rückblick sagen muss, auf Wire, also auch so diese Idee mit Mail-Server-Überlasten und so. Also das, was heute so wirkliche Probleme im Netz sind, von Bots und Spam und so weiter, das wurde ja damals dann auch noch so als digitaler Aktivismus gepriesen. Nicht so sehr vom Club, aber es gab auf jeden Fall diesen Begriff des Haktivism, was eigentlich sehr viel mehr so aus dem mexikanischen Widerstand dann eben auch in den USA geprägt wurde. Gruppen, die eben den Widerstand in Netzen sozusagen hoch gelobt haben zu dem Äquivalent zur Straßenbesetzung und Demo und Blockade, was ja der gängige Widerstand in der realen physikalischen Welt war. Und dann eben der Versuch, das dann so eins zu eins auf digitale Netze zu übertragen. Man, das ist ja etwas, was der Club dann auch später eigentlich so nie verfolgt hat. Und ich denke, so ist es auch immer noch, dass wir halt sagen, don't mess with other people's data beziehungsweise auch don't mess with other people's infrastructure. Also man soll halt eigentlich nicht Infrastrukturen gefährden, weil letztlich kann man damit wenig bewirken. Zumindest sehe ich das so. Du rümpfst die Nase.
Na ja, guck, also ich meine Infrastruktur in Infrastruktur. Also natürlich muss man aufpassen, wenn man Infrastruktur angreift, dass man jetzt nicht den Notrufnamen legt oder so. Aber wir reden hier von dem Wählen von 0-130er-Nummern. Ich glaube nicht, dass man allein mit der Anzahl der Nummern, die es gegeben hat zu dem Zeitpunkt, das war nicht irre groß. Also das waren vielleicht zwei, drei DIN-A4-Seiten oder so, die wir da durch die Gegend gefaxt haben und ähnliche Geschichten. Und die Leute, die dann angerufen haben, was war das schon?
Ja gut, aber dann kann man auch sagen, das ist sinnlos.
Das ist es ja nicht, weil du schon auf der anderen Seite Callcenter unter Last legst. Und ich meine, was kannst du denn machen? Du kannst der Botschaft deine Faxe schicken. Oder du kannst dann noch in Anführungsstrichen das ganze Volk in Sippenhaft nehmen und sagen, ihr habt die gewählt, die da jetzt gerade wieder anfangen, Atom-Tests zu machen und deswegen müssen jetzt auch die Callcenter-Agents leiden.
Womit wir dann schon eigentlich eher bei der medialen Aussage sind. Dass man eigentlich so eine Aktion deshalb startet, um Medieninteresse zu erzeugen, um Aufmerksamkeit auf das Thema zu legen.
Richtig, und die Aufmerksamkeit ist ja da gewesen.
Das stimmt. Ja, jetzt machst du das nicht mehr. Jetzt bist du kein Sprecher mehr. Wir haben viele andere, die dem nachgefolgt sind. Aber du hast ja immer noch so eine kleine Traditionsveranstaltung auf dem Kongress, die ich immer verpasse. Das ist ja erschütternd. Naja, weil es die letzte Veranstaltung ist vor der Abschlussveranstaltung.
Du arbeitest an deinem eigenen Vortrag.
Genau, da sitze ich dann immer und muss alles zusammen tragen, was sich so auf dem Kongress so ereignet hat und was in letzter Minute noch so an Zahlen und Anekdoten gemacht wird. Das andere, was mich davon abhält danach, wenn ich dann doch meinen Vortrag vorhabe, ist, dass diese Veranstaltung mal maßlos überfüllt ist und man überhaupt gar nicht mehr reinkommt in den Raum. Wie lange macht ihr das jetzt schon, die Security Nightmares, eure Voraussagen?
Wir haben angefangen zu dem Kongress, der das letzte Mal lief im Haus am köllischen Park. Wann war der letzte Kongress im Haus am köllischen Park?
Das war der 19.3. und der war im Jahr 2002, Ende 2002. Da war das erste Mal?
Das war das erste Mal.
Das hat schon ganz gut Tradition jetzt gewonnen.
Dann sind es fünfmal. Die Presse hat schon im zweiten Jahr von der traditionellen Veranstaltung gesprochen. So ist das. Aber das ist auch etwas, was sehr viel Spaß macht, weil man einmal den Ernst der Lage mit einer gehörigen Portion von Schadenfreude, also Schaden vor Freude, was ja noch viel besser ist.
Wir wussten es schon vorher.
Genau, und solchen Sachen verbinden kann. Es gibt Jahre, da sind wir besser drauf, und es gibt Jahre, da sind wir nicht ganz so gut drauf. Das gilt auch fürs Publikum. Ein Jahr, das war unglaublich. Da hatte noch jemand so eine Hupe mitgebracht, wie vom Fußballspiel. Genau, Honk. Und da ging richtig die Post ab. Aber letztes Jahr war auch wieder richtig gut, dass das Publikum auch gut mitgegangen ist.
Aber noch keine Fahnen?
Nee, Fahnen hab ich noch keine gesehen.
Das fehlt mir. Ihr müsst das Kongressgebäude in eine Westkurve verwandeln. We're getting there. Na gut, das war jetzt ein ausuferndes Intro, um eigentlich auf ein Thema zu kommen, was nun wirklich mit dem allen überhaupt nichts zu tun hat. Aber vielleicht dann doch ein bisschen, weil wir sind nun beide seit Ewigkeiten im Club. Und warum ist man im Club? Man ist im Club, weil man einfach so eine Affinität hat für Technik und Technologie im Allgemeinen. Und wann auch immer man dann selber mal in die Situation kommt, wo man sich so mit einem größeren Projekt, wo es um Technik geht, sei es im Business, sei es im privaten Bereich, konfrontiert sieht, dann tendiert man dazu, das kennst du sicherlich, die Sache dann auch sehr umfassend in Angriff zu nehmen.
Ja, man will das dann alles wissen. Und bevor man es nicht verstanden hat, hört man nicht auf. Und bevor man nicht einen kleinen Vortrag drüber halten kann oder ein, zwei Tage darüber sprechen kann am Stück, hört man nicht auf.
So, und in deinem Fall, und jetzt sind wir dann auch endlich mal beim Thema angelangt, handelt es sich um das Selbstbauen. Ich weiß nicht, habt ihr selber gebaut oder bauen lassen?
Wir haben die Luxus-Variante gewählt mit bauen lassen, grundum, sorglos, Schlüssel fertig, Ende zu Ende, inklusive Auffahrt, Anschlüsse und jedem allen.
Okay, und zwar ein Haus.
Genau.
Schaffe, schaffe, häusle, baue, oder vielleicht auch mal häusle, baue, lasse. Und trotz alledem, man will ja nicht irgendwie nur so ein Haus aus dem Katalog haben, sondern man möchte es ja dann in ordentlich haben oder wie wir dann immer sagen, das Rechts-Unten-Modell. Kennst du den Begriff eigentlich?
Das Rechts-Unten-Modell?
Ja, das Rechts-Unten-Modell. Das haben wir immer so eingeführt, den Begriff, als Apple anfing, seine Produkte in so einer einfachen Produktmatrix, sind ja zwei Mal zwei Matrix, so Consumer und Pro. Und dann gab es so die Minimalausstattung und die Maximalausstattung. Und eigentlich wollte man immer so das Rechts-Unten-Modell haben, sozusagen das Profimodell in der Maximalausstattung. Und das ist dann so zum geflügelten Wort bei uns geworden.
Und das setzen die nach rechts unten und nicht nach rechts oben?
Na links oben sind dann so Consumer und unten... Also oben war so iBook und iMac und darunter war dann halt so, was heute MacBook Pro heißt, also PowerBook und dann halt die Power Macs, also heute die Mac Pros.
Das heißt, die Sachen, von denen sie gedacht haben, dass sie große Mengen im Sinne von Volumen gemacht haben, die haben sie nach rechts oben gebracht?
Beziehungsweise links waren halt einfach nur... Also von oben nach unten hast du halt die Produkte gehabt und von links nach rechts hast du sie halt in der verschiedenen Ausstattung. Also wenn du jetzt so ein Produkt geklickt hast, so ich will Laptop haben, dann hat sie halt so von oben nach unten Laptop mit irgendwie, ja, mit wenig und dann mit mehr und mit mehr und mit Brenner und tralala und dann halt auch noch in verschiedenen Ausbaustufen. Keine Ahnung, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall, das rechts unten Modell ist einfach immer das, was man irgendwie haben will, da wird gar nicht gefragt. Ja, und was ist das jetzt, wenn man sich ein Haus baut? Was ist denn das rechts unten Modell?
Die Villa mit Vorfahrts? Das rechts unten Modell ist, glaube ich, das, woran Leute wie Carsten gerade dran planen, mit sehr langem Horizont. Wenn man einfach davor steht, das zu bauen, dann guckt man sich natürlich an, was man zahlen kann. Und dann schaut man, was geht. Und die Spanne ist enorm. Du kannst so bediebig viel Geld ausgeben für Dinge rund um den Hausbau. Allein im Bad kannst du Zehntausende versenken. Dasselbe gilt für die Küche, dasselbe gilt für Wohnzimmer, Bodenbelege und alles Mögliche. Dass man sich schon sehr genau überlegen muss, was man denn eigentlich haben will und wo man seine Schwerpunkte setzt. Und natürlich ist es da immer sinnvoll zu sagen, was sind die Dinge, die ich später sowieso nie mehr ändern kann? Und dort dann Schwerpunkte zu setzen, weil man bei den anderen Dingen vielleicht noch mal nachlegen kann. Also natürlich gibt es eine Menge Leute, die sagen, ich gebe jetzt erstmal bin ich für die Küche aus und dann mache ich in fünf Jahren was Neues, was sie dann natürlich doch nie tun. Never underestimate the lifetime of a quick fix oder so ähnlich.
Jaja, ist aber in der realen Welt nicht anders als ein Software.
Genau, ist es ja wirklich nicht. Und da sind wir schon wieder bei einem interessanten Punkt, nämlich der Vergleichbarkeit zwischen Häusern und Software. Also da kann man eigentlich fast ein Buch drüber schreiben. Ja, weil die Leute denken immer ich kaufe ein Haus oder so, oder ich lasse mir eins bauen oder so. Und dann wird ja auch irgendwie simuliert, dass das ein Produkt wäre, ein Haus, weil es gibt ja Kataloge, in denen du blättern kannst, mit Grundrissen, dann kannst du sagen, ich hätte gern das hier. Und dann kannst du vielleicht noch ein bisschen rumklicken und sagen, und dann mit dem Feature, mit dem Feature, mit dem Feature. Und was wird simuliert, ist, wer ein Produkt wie ein Auto ein Produkt ist. Vielleicht, ja. Und werden auch immer viel gerne Vergleiche gezogen. Und das ist aber alles totaler Bullshit, weil ein Haus, ja, eigentlich immer, und selbst Fertighäuser ist das so, gebaut werden als Projekt von Leuten. Und das ist dann schon wieder so ähnlich wie mit, ich hab da meinen Softwarearchitekten und dann hab ich da meinen Subject Matter Expert für die Wände hochziehen. Und der hat dann aber auch genau keine Ahnung von Putz, der hinterher auf die Wände kommt. Und der mit dem Putz, der macht dann noch den Estrich. Aber der hat halt natürlich keine Ahnung von der Elektrik. Und der Elektriker hat wieder keine Ahnung von den Rohren fürs Abwasser und Wasser und so weiter.
Das Bauherrentum ist mit einigen Strafen versehen. Ich hab mich mit einigen Bauherren in den letzten Jahren mal unterhalten. Und jetzt, wo du das sagst, die Geschichten, die man da hört, gerade durch diese Verpeilung von unterschiedlichen Bauteilnehmern, die eigentlich von dem anderen immer nichts verstehen.
Auch keine Rücksicht, ne? Im Zweifelsfall.
Genau, ich erinnere mich da an eine geile Geschichte von einem Gebäude. Ich sag jetzt mal nicht welchem, aber im Keller gab es so einen Raum. Und den hat er mir dann als Endergebnis gezeigt, um mir mal zu zeigen, was so Verpeilung auf dem Bau real bewirken kann. Ja, guck mal dieser Raum. Und dann machte er so die Tür auf. Und die Tür ließ sich aber nicht ganz öffnen, weil dahinter war eine Heizung. Was ganz interessant war, weil an der Wand gab es auch einen Magnetanschlag, wo diese Tür theoretisch anschlagen sollte. Aber die Tür war gar nicht in der Lage, diesen Anschlag jemals zu erreichen, weil halt die Heizung hinter der Tür angebaut war. Denkt man sich scheiß Planung. Aber das Lustige ist, diese Heizung hätte da niemals sein sollen, weil es handelte sich um einen Kühlraum. Und solche Sachen gab es da irgendwie zu hauf. Also wenn man nicht irgendwie schwer aufpasst, kann einem da ganz schön was verkackt werden. Aber dein Fokus war ja jetzt bei dem Haus ein, ein Tja, Energiesparhaus, Niedrigenergiehaus, wie auch immer man das nennen soll. Also ein Haus, was mit möglichst wenig Energiekosten auskommt, zu bauen.
Mit weniger. Also ich muss da ehrlich sagen, das ist nicht die Rechtsrundenvariante, sondern das ist die weniger.
Okay, so in der Mitte die Spalte.
Ja, das ist so die, ja, ziemlich genau in der Mitte die Spalte, wenn man mal, aber da halten wir uns darüber, was die Mitte ist. Erstmal ist es ja so, dass dieser Begriff Niedrige Energiehaus oder Energiesparhaus, krieg ich schon immer Ausschlag, wenn ich das höre. Warum? Weil ich immer das Gefühl habe, jeder, der diesen Begriff verwendet, will jemanden anders übers Ohr hauen. Die Leute sagen immer, wir verkaufen, wir bauen ihnen ein Energiesparhaus. Wir bauen ihnen ein Niedrige Energiehaus. Und wenn du dich ein bisschen damit beschäftigst, heißt, weißt du, dass das nicht definiert ist. Der Begriff ist nicht definiert. Ein Energiesparhaus ist alles oder nichts. Es gibt Leute, die bauen dir ein Niedrige Energiehaus. Und sie bauen es einfach nach gesetzlicher Vorgabe. Weil Häuser gerade und frecherweise auf eine Art, frecherweise Häuser zum Wohnen, zum drinnen wohnen, sind klar geregelt, was die maximal verbrauchen dürfen an Primärenergie. Das wird in der...
Grundsätzlich.
Grundsätzlich. Nee, nicht schon immer. Ich glaube, das erste Mal hat man angefangen, Ende der 70er, nach dem ersten Ölschock, das Ganze zu regeln. Und dann kam irgendwann die Wärmeschutzverordnung, ich glaube, 95 oder vielleicht auch schon 90 und 95. Und dann 2000, um das Jahr 2000 herum, kam die sogenannte Energieeinsparverordnung.
Dann schon von Rot-Grün.
Energieeinsparverordnung, ENEV. Die definiert zwei Ebenen. Nämlich einmal die Qualität der Hülle des Hauses. Also deiner Wände, Fenster, Dach und so weiter. Also die Hülle, die deinen Wohnraum umschließt. Und die maximale Primärenergie, die du durchsetzen darfst. Um dein Haus warm zu machen. Und die Wärmeschutzverordnung 95, ich glaube um diese Zeit muss dieser Begriff Niedrige Energiehaus eingeführt worden sein. Das war einfach das, was man dann gebaut hat. Ein Niedrige Energiehaus nach Wärmeschutzverordnung 95. Musste man ja. Und dann die Energieeinsparverordnung hat die Latte noch mal höher gesetzt. Das heißt, wenn du den Standard von 95...
Das ist also niedriger. Also je nachdem ob man oben drüber oder drunter...
Eine Latte setzt man glaube ich immer höher.
Beim Lambada tanzen muss man sich ja immer weiter biegen.
Da werden dann nicht Türen runter gesetzt. So ist sozusagen das, was man 95, wenn man gesagt hat 95, die Wärmeschutzverordnung definiert den Standard. Wenn dann etwas besser ist, könnte man es natürlich Niedrige Energiehaus nennen oder Niedrigere Energiehaus. Aber das, was 95 etwas besseres war als das, was vorgeschrieben war, wurde 2002 zum Standard. Und dann haben sie 2004 noch mal hochgedreht. Und dieses Jahr 2007 haben sie noch mal wieder ein bisschen an der Schraube gedreht.
An welcher Schraube wird da gedreht? Wie wird das bemessen? Was ist jetzt die Größe, die an der Stelle herangezogen wird? Geht es jetzt um Kilowatt oder um Wärmeabstrahlung?
Das sind genau diese beiden Parameter. Einmal die Qualität der Hülle. Die wird über den sogenannten Transmissionswiderstand definiert.
Also was effektiv an Wärme das Haus verlässt.
Genau, den Verlust. Oder anders gesagt, das ist ein Widerstand, der definiert wird, das was dem Wärmeverlust entgegengesetzt wird.
Also was an Isolierung letztlich ins Haus eingebracht wird.
Genau, die Qualität der Isolierung, der Dämmung wird definiert über einen sogenannten U-Wert. Und da gibt es unterschiedliche Geschichten. Also ich mach mal, was mach ich mal für ein Beispiel. Ein Fenster heutzutage hat typischerweise einen Wert von 1,3. Ist glaube ich typisch mit Rahmen. Während eine Wand einen Wert hat von 0,3 möglich, alles kein Problem. Nur um das mal ins Verhältnis zu setzen.
0,3, was ist jetzt die Einheit da?
Das ist irgendwie keine Ahnung. Kelvin mal Team Pimal Daum über die Zeit bei.
Okay, also eine Wand macht dich da als irgendwie eine Tür.
Eine Wand dämmt mehr als ein Fenster, ist klar.
Kommt aufs Fenster an, würde ich sagen.
Kommt aufs Fenster an, aber selbst ein gutes Fenster, selbst wenn du ein richtig gutes Fenster holst, dann bist du nachher mit einem U-Wert von 0,0 irgendwas. Aber eben noch ziemlich dicht an der 1 dran und eine Wand kann locker 0,5 schaffen. Also das ist einfach viel, viel besser. Das ist das eine, das steht fast nie im Vordergrund, interessanterweise so in der Diskussion, sondern in der Diskussion steht immer im Vordergrund der Verbrauch über die primäre Energie gemessen. Und da ist es immer so dieses, kennst wahrscheinlich den Begriff, 7 Liter Haus oder 3 Liter Haus?
Ich finde das nur im Bezug aufs Auto.
3 Liter Auto, gut, ja klar, die Leute kennen das 3 Liter Auto. Ein sehr populärer Begriff ist der des 3 Liter Hauses. Weil die Leute dann sagen, das ist ein Haus, das braucht 3 Liter pro Quadratmeter pro Jahr zum Heizen. 3 Liter Öl.
Na ja, das hängt auf die Quadratmeter an.
Kommt drauf an, wie ich dich verarschen will. Ich kann hinstellen und sagen, 3 Liter Öl sind 30 Kilowatt. Also Kilowattstunden, 30 Kilowattstunden. Pro Jahr. Und wenn ich sage, das ist die Premiere-Energie, die ich reinstecke, ist da immer die Frage, wie viel kommt nachher an? Und da kann ich anfangen, Leute zu verarschen, indem ich sage, das ist ein 3-Liter-Haus. Was meine ich mit den 3 Litern? Meine ich die 3 Liter, die ich vorne reinstecke? Ja, weil eine Öl, also gerade eine Ölheizung, arbeitet nicht mit einem Wirkungsgrad von 1, oder 100%. Also die arbeitet mit einem Wirkungsgrad von 60, übers Jahr gesehen, wenn du Glück hast. Und da ist noch gar nicht der Strom drin, den sie verbraucht. Wenn ich 3 Liter vorne reinstecke, kommt nicht für 3 Liter Wärme in deinem Haus an. Und dann ist natürlich wieder die Frage, wenn die Wärme erst mal in dem Haus drin ist, wie diffundiert sie wieder raus? Wie dicht ist dein Haus? Hast du eine Lüftungsanlage? Hast du keine? Und ähnliche Geschichten. Oder ich kann losgehen und sagen, ich sage, mit den 3 Litern meine ich eigentlich die Energie, die im Haus benötigt wird, um es warm zu machen. Also da wird viel geschummelt, wenn man sich mit Leuten unterhält. Aber die Energieeinsprachverordnung, die sorgt dafür, dass man da eigentlich nicht schummeln kann, sondern die definiert ganz klar Maximalgrenzen für den Primärenergieverbrauch. Eine Primärenergie wäre zum Beispiel Öl oder Gas.
Das heißt, ich habe jetzt ein Haus mit 200 Quadratmetern Nutzfläche. Was sagt jetzt die Verordnung, was ich da maximal an Energie verbraten darf in diesem Haus?
Das ist egal, wie groß das Haus ist tatsächlich. Die Energieeinsparverordnung, das, was 2004 Standard war, habe ich jetzt gerade im Kopf. Da durfte ein Einfamilienhaus freistehend auf der Wiese ungefähr einen Primärenergieverbrauch haben von maximal 120 Kilowattstunden pro Quadratmeter pro Jahr. Das ist also einfach mal Standard. Das ist ziemlich guter Standard. Ich glaube, der Bestand hat einen durchschnittlichen Verbrauch von über 300 Kilowattstunden pro...
Also mit Bestand meinst du jetzt alle Häuser, die derzeit so in Deutschland rumstehen im Schnitt?
Genau. Der ist deutlich höher. Entweder waren das 300 Kilowattstunden.
Das heißt, würde man durch einen Zauberschnips alle Häuser auf den aktuellen Standard bringen können, würde sich der Gesamtenergieverbrauch, der durch Wohnen aufgebracht wird, schon mal gut halbieren?
Ja, mehr als halbieren.
Das ist natürlich nicht so, ohne weiteres zu machen.
Klar, es ist aber auch nicht schwer zu machen. Man kann ein Bestandhaus auf Passivhaus runterbringen, wenn man das will. Rein materialtechnisch und auch, was man einem Haus so antun kann, in Anführungsstrichen. Und was so einer alten Bausubstanz antun kann, kannst du ein Bestandshaus auf Passivhausniveau runterbringen. Da bin ich dann aber schon bei einem anderen Thema, nämlich was ist dann ein Passivhaus. Also, Niedrigenergiehaus, ich mach den Begriff deswegen nicht, weil er nicht definiert ist. Definiert ist das, was das Gesetz vorschreibt, Energieeinsparverordnung, 120 Kilowattstunden pro Quadratmeter pro Jahr maximal. Und dann gibt es eben noch so 2, 3 andere Dinge, die definiert sind. Es gibt diesen Begriff des Passivhauses. Ein Passivhaus nach passivhaus.de, Dr. Feist und so weiter, nach Passivhaus Standard, ist dann wieder ein Haus, das braucht nur, wie war denn das, 15 Watt Heizleistung pro Quadratmeter.
Also gut so...
Ich rede jetzt gerade wieder von Watt, das sind nicht Kilowattstunden, das ist wieder eine andere Baustelle. Weil sich ein Passivhaus anders definiert. Das definiert sich nicht über den Maximalverbrauch, sondern das definiert sich zum Beispiel darüber, dass es keine konventionelle Heizung braucht. Sondern ein Passivhaus ist per Definition ein Haus, das du alleine über die Erwärmung von Luft heizen kannst. Und über Luft kannst du eben nicht besonders viel Energie transportieren. Weil Luft... Eigentlich das, was in der Luft Energie transportiert, ist das Wasser, das da drin ist. Und das ist eben nicht besonders viel. Und deswegen ist 15 Watt Leistung das, was du reinbringen kannst, über die Luft pro Quadratmeter. Mehr ist nicht drin, alles andere wird dann füllen wie in der Sahara. Dann wirst du immer so vorm Wüstensturm stehen oder so. Und da hat natürlich auch keiner überhaupt drauf. So, das ist ein Passivhaus, das ist auch klar definiert. Und das kostet dann natürlich ein bisschen mehr, so was zu bauen. Und dann gibt es noch zwei sehr schöne andere Standards, die definiert sind. Nämlich von der Kreditanstalt für Wiederaufbau, die energiesparsames Häusle bauen, fördern. Wo man dann also sich einen Kredit holen kann, zu guten Konditionen, wenn man besser baut als... Der Standard. Der Standard, der ENEV-Standard.
Also wenn man unter diesen 120 Kilowattstunden pro Jahr bleibt.
Und zwar nicht irgendwie unter, sondern da gibt es genau zwei definierte Niveaus. Das ist einmal KfW 60. Das heißt 60 Kilowattstunden pro Quadratmeter pro Jahr. Primär Energieverbrauch. Also die Hälfte. Und KfW 40. Das ist dann entsprechend ein Drittel. So, und KfW 60 ist jetzt eine tolle Sache, weil es ungefähr die Hälfte ist. Ja, KfW, Kreditanstalt für Wiederaufbau. Ach so, okay, danach. Die Institution, die das einfach mal definiert hat, damit sie was hat, was sie fördern kann. So, und ich sagte ja vorhin schon, es wird immer so ein Wert gelegt auf diese 120 oder 60 oder 40 oder 15 von Passiv oder so. Das ist aber immer nur ein Kriterium. Das andere Kriterium ist, dass auch bei KfW 60 und 40 der Transmissionswiderstand deutlich höher sein muss, also deutlich besser sein muss als beim Standard. Also nicht nur der Verbrauch muss geringer sein, sondern der absolute Bedarf muss kleiner sein.
Passivhaus senkt das im Prinzip alles auf Null ab, oder wie?
Naja, nicht auf Null, aber auf so wenig, dass du das über warme Luft ausgleichen kannst. So, das ist der Trick. Du brauchst nichts mehr. Keine Fußbodenheizung, keine Wandheizung, keine Radiatoren oder so.
Was hast du jetzt gebaut?
Wir haben KfW 60 gebaut.
Das ist aber auch schon eine nennenswerte Anstrengung, das zu erreichen?
Ja, das ist, KfW 60 hat, ich würde es nicht nochmal machen, ich würde das nächste Mal gleich KfW 40 bauen. Aber nur, weil ich jetzt weiß, dass das Geld noch gereicht hätte, was ich als wir angefangen haben nicht gewusst habe. Und KfW 60 kostet etwa bei so einem Durchschnittshaus mit 120 bis 140 qm Wohnfläche, kostet das etwa 10.000 Euro mehr. KfW 60. Und für 10.000 Euro für die Hälfte, in Anführungsstrichen, Heizen und das über die Laufzeit, das rechnet sich tatsächlich schon. Aber bei den aktuellen Energiepreisen, interessanterweise, nur knapp, wenn man alles rechnet. Also Zins, Zinseszins, Mehrbelastung, blablabla. Das ist ein ganz interessanter Punkt, dass wenn man anfängt solche Sachen durchzurechnen, stellt man sehr schnell fest, dass Energie eigentlich noch ganz schön billig ist. Ölpreis 100 Euro oder 100 Dollar. Die Welt regt sich auf. Und wenn du dann mal anfängst, versuchst durchzurechnen, wie viel mehr Geld kann ich eigentlich ausgeben? Und dann rechnet sich auch unter Berücksichtigung ganz ehrlich von allem, dann ist es im Moment nicht so viel. Aber natürlich gehen wir nicht davon aus, dass der Ölpreis bei 100 Dollar stehen bleibt.
Ja, ich weiß nicht. Aber derzeit sieht es zumindest nicht danach aus, ob er sich mal so eben wieder besonders sinken wird bei den großen Nachfragen, die weltweit entfinden.
Das ist eher unwahrscheinlich, genau.
Mit anderen Worten, man kann auch damit rechnen, dass die Energiepreise hochgehen. Und das wird natürlich dann auch auf diese Berechnung großen Einfluss haben, das heißt niedrig, jetzt hab ich schon fast wieder das böse Wort gesagt, also Energiesparhäuser, Häuser mit weniger Energieverbrauch werden sich mehr rechnen künftig.
Genau, das Interessante ist, sagte ich das schon, was eigentlich auf eine Art gemein ist, dass Bürohäuser gar nicht so hohe Anforderungen gestellt werden. Find ich persönlich jetzt eine Frechheit.
Ja, Wohnhäuser, ach.
Ich weiß gar nicht ehrlich gesagt warum, vielleicht weil die Lobby besser ist oder so. Den ganzen kleinen Häuslebauern, denen kann man das aufdrücken. Und die großen Bürohäuser, die müssen das alle nicht.
Die sind ja nur tagsüber da.
Naja, die sind natürlich auch durchgeheizt, damit man morgens nicht ins kalte Büro kommt.
Ja, außerdem müssen die Sklaven auch nachts durchrockern.
Also ist, ja, wie auch immer. Also gut, das ist halt KfW 60. Und das muss man jetzt halt zu einem Teil erreichen, in dem man die Dämmung besser macht als beim Standard. Und den anderen Teil reicht man über die Haustechnik. Das heißt, die Art und Weise, wie man das Haus tatsächlich warm macht.
Dann bleiben wir doch vielleicht mal kurz bei dieser Isolierungsfrage. Also ich meine, so Doppelglas-Fenster, das hat natürlich jeder schon mal gehört. Das ist so eine einfache Geschichte. Ich baue mir irgendwie neue Fenster rein. Ich meine, nicht wenige Häuser oder vor allem auch Mietswohnungen haben einfach noch so Einfachglas. Und da kann man natürlich schon eine ganze Menge allein dadurch erreichen. Nehme ich mal an. Durchgerechnet habe ich es jetzt nicht. Aber es ist definitiv wärmer, wenn man Doppelglasverglasung hat. Aber was kann man denn jetzt vor allem bei so einem Bestandshaus machen? Also wird das eigentlich auch gefördert, wenn ich jetzt mein Mischunghaus habe? Ich möchte das ganz gerne auf KfW, was auch immer, 6040 umwandeln. Im gleichen Maße wie beim Neubau. Oder ist das sogar noch toller?
Oh, also da bin ich mit den Zahlen nicht auf dem letzten Stand. Aber das wird signifikant gefördert. Auch von der Kreditanstalt für Wiederaufbau. Wenn es nicht noch lokal gefördert wird, von der jeweiligen Stadt oder Gemeinde, in der man wohnt. Die fördern das. Und im Sinne von günstigen Krediten.
Und was kann man jetzt machen? Was senkt diesen Transmissionswiderstand meiner Außenhülle am effektivsten? Was für Maßnahmen habt ihr hier ergriffen?
Bei uns ist es im Wesentlichen der Ziegel, mit dem gebaut wird. Man nimmt einen Ziegel, der entsprechend dick ist und entsprechend viel Luft einschließt. Weil Luft dämmt ganz toll, wenn sie sich nicht bewegt. Man muss sehr aufpassen, dass sie sich nicht bewegt. In dem Stein oder so. Dann natürlich klassisch Mineralwolle. Dann entsprechend dick und in der entsprechenden Qualität. Das ist ein Punkt, den ich auch immer wichtig finde. Man kann mit Dämmung auf zwei Ebenen besser werden. Einmal kann man mehr dämmen. Du kannst einfach dicker dämmen.
Oder besser dämmen.
Oder besser. Du nimmst etwas, was besser dämmt. Da gibt es dann Wärmeleitgruppen. WLG 035 ist ein typischer Stand. WLG 30 wäre besser. Das kann man auch noch bezahlen. WLG 25 kann man zwar kaufen, aber nicht mehr bezahlen. Wobei sich das natürlich fortentwickelt. Der Heilige Gral sind diese Sachen, von denen man ab und zu liest. Wo dann irgendwelche Forschungseinrichtungen sagen, sie können jetzt schon Vakuum in lustige kleine Gesteins- oder Keramik- oder sonst was Geschichten einsperren und dann Vakuum-Panels bauen. Ich meine, Luft dämmt super. Aber ein Raum, in dem nichts ist, was Wärme bewegen kann, ein Vakuum, das dämmt am allerbesten. Wenn ich also ein Vakuum einschließen könnte, dann brauche ich nur wenige Millimeter, um dasselbe zu erreichen, was diese 40-50 cm Wand hinter dir erreicht.
Da nimmt man aber keine Ziegel, oder?
Brauchst du dann ja nicht mehr.
Womit schließe ich das Vakuum dann ein?
Die machen jetzt gerade mit so lustigen kleinen Steinchen rum. Kieselsäure, tra la la, irgendwas habe ich noch im Kopf.
Das heißt, da wird dann sozusagen was geformt, so Terraforming-mäßig.
Die nehmen so wie so ein, wie heißen diese Steine, die machen das wie so ein Käse, da sind halt ganz viele Löcher drin, nur dass da halt ein Vakuum drin ist. Und das ist natürlich dann super, wenn man sowas machen kann. Die Problematik bei diesen Vakuum-Sachen ist nur, dass das Vakuum irgendwann wieder raus ist.
Also es hält dann trotzdem, das ist richtig toll.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie die aktuellen Zahlen sind. Sie sagen, sie werden immer besser und dass es sich jetzt lohnen würde, weil das Vakuum ja doch, keine Ahnung, fünf bis zehn oder fünfzehn Jahre halten würde.
Vielleicht muss man ja dann alle fünf Jahre einfach seine Häuser wieder einreißen und ein neues Vakuum installieren oder mit einem Staubsauger mal rangehen.
Also ich persönlich, ich hoffe ja, dass man in ein paar Jahren, also fünf bis zehn Jahren, so eine kleine Nanoroboter kaufen kann. Weißt du, die nehme ich einfach. Kauf mir eine Tüte von diesen Nanorobotern, kipp sie hier in die Lüftungsschlitze von meinem Außenklinker und programmier sie dann dazu, dass sie meine Mineralwolle umbauen in Vakuum-Panels. Das rettet den Bestand. Derjenige, der sowas erfindet...
Meinst du, dass er diese Glasfaser nimmt und da irgendwie Vakuum-Einschlüsse reinbaut?
Wieso? Für einen Nanoroboter ist doch alles Materie. Oder der nimmt die ganzen Atome meiner Mineralwolle und baut mir dann daraus aus den, keine Ahnung, 12 cm Mineralwolle, 1 cm Vakuum-Panel.
Ah, also richtig so komplett umarbeiten, meinst du?
Ja.
So ein Verdauungsvorgang, sozusagen. Nachfallen die Dinger rülpsend nach getaner Arbeit aus der Wolle und hinterlassen einfach ein Vakuum.
Das ist doch das, was wir haben wollen.
Das ist das, was wir haben wollen. Aber soweit ist die Technik noch nicht. Also muss man irgendwie ordentlich isolieren. Sprich, du hast einen tollen Ziegel. Muss man sich die dann selber aussuchen?
Du musst durch den totalen Durchblicksstrudel gehen, um den Ziegel auszuwählen. Oder du machst das, was dein Architekt ist.
Gibt es dann auch so ein Ziegel-Porn-Kataloger?
Es gibt Religionskriege. Es gibt Leute, die beschimpfen den einen Ziegelstein als den Krümelkeks und fluchen darauf und sagen, das kann nicht sein. Andere Leute sagen, Ziegel ist böse. Andere sagen, nur Ziegel kann man überhaupt nehmen. Mineralwölle ist böse.
Es ist irre.
Die Betriebssystemkriege sind nichts dagegen.
Was ist das angesagte OS im Ziegelbereich? Wofür hast du dich entschieden? Kannst du da konkreter werden? Ist es ein Ziegelprodukt oder eine Ziegelart, für die man sich entscheidet? Gibt es von jeder Art, die man haben kann, viele Hersteller? Oder gibt es einzelne Hersteller, die den total mega super Dämmziegel bauen?
Es gibt schon ein paar Sachen, die sind, wenn man das versucht, ohne die Religionsbrille zu betragen, ziemlich high-end. Das haben wir hier noch nicht gemacht, aber es gibt da so Ziegel wie den T9. Das ist letztendlich ein gewöhnlicher Porotonziegel. Nur da, wo bei einem normalen Porotonziegel einfach nur kleine Luftschächte sind, dort ist halt so Vulkan-Gebrösel drin. Und das schließt halt Luft sehr effektiv ein, sorgt dafür, dass sich die Luft nicht bewegt und sorgt dadurch dafür, dass es da ganz tolle Dämmwerte erreicht werden.
Vulkanbrösel?
Ja, Vulkangesteins-tra-la-la.
Das heißt, da wird dann noch der Vesuv abgetragen?
Nee, das wird ja alles künstlich hergestellt.
Wie künstliche Vulkane?
Na, du weißt schon, dieses lustige, kleine, bröselige, lufteinschlüssige, ne, so ähnlich wie Lava-esque, tra-la-la.
Da wird dann so Steine erhitzt und beblubbert, sozusagen.
Das wird da reingegossen.
Steinschaum.
Ja, das wird da irgendwie reingemacht.
Ich glaube, ich habe einen Freund, dessen Vater eine Ziegelei hat. Als er mir das erste Mal erzählt hat, dachte ich mir so, Ziegelei, da kann man ja so vor, wie so ein Beruf wie Köhler.
Wie gewöhnlich und wie lang kann man denn mit einer Ziegelei in dieser modernen Zeit überleben?
Aber die sind innovativ, da werden richtig Dinge hergestellt, die die Welt noch nicht gesehen hat. Und gerade bei diesen Themen Dämmung bei gleichzeitigem Nicht-Krümmelkeks sein. Also nicht irgendwie bröselig sein und irgendwie schlecht zu verarbeiten. Das muss ja nicht nur ein Stein sein, der was aushält und der was dämmt, sondern der muss dann auch noch vernünftig verarbeitbar sein von so einem Durchschnittsmauer. Weil bis die Roboter anfangen, die Wände zu mauern, das dauert noch ein Weilchen. Also es gibt schon, du kannst schon dein Haus kaufen, wo die Wände von Robotern hochgezogen werden und so, das gibt es schon. Ich hab mal ein Video gesehen im Interweb, wo gezeigt wurde, wie sie die von Robotern gemauerten Wände vom Laster laden und dann nur noch das Haus zusammenstecken. Im Zeitraffer sehr abgefahren. Da ist dann natürlich auch das Überbindmaß, alles völlig korrekt eingehalten und so weiter.
Gut, also mit Ziegeln geht es los. Und ich weiß nicht, hast du jetzt gesagt...
Das ist eine Variante, das gibt ja die andere Religion.
Was für einen Ziegler hast du denn genommen?
Wir haben hier einen relativ gewöhnlichen mittleren Oberklasse T17 genommen.
T17 heißt das. Aber es gibt dann auch so rechts unten Modell... T9.
Genau, mit V-Plus-System und so weiter. Schieß mich tot.
Es ist aber wieder erstaunlich, wie auch wirklich so offensichtlich gewöhnliche Dinge dann doch eine technische Tiefe immer wieder aufbringen können. Das ist unglaublich. Ja, so, das heißt, man wählt den richtigen Ziegel aus. Trotz aller Demos muss auf die Mauer dann auch noch was rauf. Oder? Nicht. Es ist einfach nur Ziegel. Du hast ja noch gesagt, Material... Du hast noch Mineralwolle irgendwie.
Ja, das ist, weil wir hier zweischalig bauen gerne im Norden. Also so mit Verblendstein draußen, Klinkerwand und so. Und dann ist es eben sehr typisch, dass man die Außenwand mit einem Ziegelmauer, dann noch Mineralwolle draufklebt, in Anführungsstrichen, und dann noch einen Klinker davor setzt, um dann so eine hübsche Klinkerwand zu haben. Und die Alternative ist dazu natürlich zu sagen, ich mache einfach einen Ziegel und dann klebe ich da ein Wärmedämmverbundsystem drauf. Und da mache ich dann Putz drauf. Dann habe ich eine Putzfassade.
Wärmedämmverbundsystem, was muss man sich darunter vorstellen? Poser.
Nur mal ganz billig gesagt, Styroporplatten. Das ist natürlich was viel Besseres und Schöneres, das hast du nicht gesehen. Aber letztendlich läuft es darauf, wenn es ungefähr aussehen aus, wie Styroporplatten, die werden dann von außen drauf geklebt. Dann kommt noch eine Folie drauf vielleicht und dann kommt Putz drauf.
Okay, Ziegel, Styropor, Folie oder auch nicht Putz.
Genau.
Das ist eine Wand.
Das ist eine Wand. Oder du machst Holzrahmenbau.
Das heißt?
Na, dann hast du halt einen Holzrahmen, also so Fachwerkhaus-mäßig, also Holzbalken, quer, längs und so weiter. Und dazwischen kommt dann Dämmung. Also richtig, das ist im Wesentlichen dann Holzgitter. Und wird dann Mineralwolle oder was man auch immer nimmt, Hanf oder ähnliche Geschichten. Gibt ja auch andere Werkstoffe. Und dann kommen OSB-Platten davor und dahinter.
OSB-Platten? Was ist das?
Eine OSB-Platte kennst du. Das sind diese Press-Pappen. Press-Pappen? Ich wusste das mal. Ich hab das mal gegoogelt, was OSB eigentlich heißt, als mich das interessiert hat, weil wir das hier unser...
Ich kann es auch gleich nochmal googeln, aber ich hab hier gerade meinen WLAN-Zugang irgendwie eingebüßt. Und ich weiß gar nicht warum. Aber vielleicht kannst du das ja nochmal hier kurz...
Das sind Span-Platten. Span-Platten, kannst du damit was anfangen? Press-Span-Platten?
Jaja, damit kann ich was anfangen.
Ist halt nicht Vollholz im Sinne von geschnittene Platte.
Also halt so Schnipsel gepresst.
Genau.
Ja, ich kenne das noch unter anderem Begriff, aber ich kann jetzt gerade auch bei OBS nichts anfangen.
Und da Holz selber auch super dämmt und dann natürlich eine Wand, die im Prinzip aus Mineralwolle besteht, ganz hervorragend dämmt, ist das natürlich auch eine super Art und Weise, sich ein Haus hinzustellen, das dann sehr gut gedämmt ist. Also Holz, Holzrahmenbau, selbst Vollholz, das gibt es auch, sich ein Haus zu bauen, wo die Wände wirklich Vollholzbalken sind. Das dämmt auch nicht so schlecht. Das ist dann natürlich immer schwierig, mit mal eine Leitung reinschlitzen, um Kabel zu verlegen.
Was macht man jetzt mit dem Rest der Hülle?
Es gibt verschiedene Fensterdicken im Sinne von Fensterscheibe. Dann kannst du zweischreibig, dreischreibig und Ähnliches machen.
Aber ihr habt nur zwei Scheiben.
Ja, wir haben zwei Scheiben. Wir haben Standard 1,3.
Also ein Bekannter von mir, der hat ja so ein ganz tolles Passivhaus. Ich glaube, das ist die richtige Bezeichnung. Und das fand ich ja schon schwer beeindruckend. Weil, und da kommen wir ja auch gleich nochmal drauf, da vor allem die Haustechnik eine große Rolle spielt. Aber das Ding ist natürlich dann vor allem, ja, so nahezu hundertprozentig dicht. Das heißt, da waren dann irgendwie drei Schichten Glas an allen Fenstern und Türen. Und zwar nicht wenig Glas, muss man dazu sagen, weil große nach Süden ausgerichtete Fensterscheiben, wo dann einfach massiv die Sonne reinbrät, die dann natürlich auch schon mal so die Grundheizung mitliefert. Denn, das ist das Besondere an diesem Passivhaus, was ich natürlich richtig verstanden habe. Alles, was sich irgendwie an Wärme innen entwickelt, also entweder durch die Sonneneinstrahlung oder auch dadurch, dass man mal eben so einen kleinen Elektroheizer anschmeißt oder auch jedes andere technische Gerät, was natürlich in seinem Betrieb Wärme erzeugt. Diese Wärme verlässt dieses Haus de facto einfach nicht. Sondern es bleibt einfach drin, denn es kann nicht raus durch die Wand, es kann nicht raus durch die Fenster, also in einem bestimmten Maße natürlich schon, aber das Allermeiste bleibt immer erhalten. Und naja, dann möchte man sagen, was ist denn mit der frischen Luft? Und das fand ich dann so den eigentlichen Clou. Die Luft wird permanent erneuert, also im Gegensatz zu jedem normalen Haus, wo man immer das Problem hat, dass man irgendwann einfach keine Luft mehr kriegt, weil die Luft einfach total veratmet ist und man dann mal ordentlich lüften muss, sprich man macht irgendwie Tür auf und so, dann fliegt natürlich auch tonnenweise Wärme raus. Wenn man es halbwegs richtig macht, dann macht man das mal ebenso im Schnelldurchlauf, dann gleich wieder zu, da hat man nicht so viel Wärme eingebüßt, aber doch so einen maximalen Gewinn an Frischluft. Nicht so in diesem Passivhaus, das ist einfach immer zu, das hat immer muss mal raus, aber normalerweise bleibt es halt zu. Und alles läuft über einen Wärmetauscher. Das heißt, die Luft, die das Haus verlässt, wird ihrer Wärme mehr oder weniger vollständig entzogen und frische Luft wird angesogen und erhält diese Wärme. Ich weiß nicht genau, sowas hast du hier auch, ne?
Ja, wir haben hier eine interessante Abart davon. Also erstmal sprichst du letztendlich zwei Themen an, nämlich einmal Dichtheit der Hülle. Das kann man inzwischen messen, das wird auch vorgeschrieben in der Energieeinsparform.
Wie misst man sowas?
Über einen Blower Door Test. Du machst in ein Fenster oder in eine Tür einen Ventilator rein, einen fetten. Und Drucksensoren-Technologie. Der macht dann zwei Sachen. Der pumpt einmal dein Haus auf. Er erzeugt einen Überdruck im Haus auf einen bestimmten Wert. Und guckt dann, wie schnell der Druck abfällt, wenn der Lüfter ausgeht. Und dann erzeugt er noch mal einen Unterdruck im Haus auf einen bestimmten Wert. Und guckt dann, wie schnell der Wert abfällt über die Zeit. Das wird dann gemittelt und da kommt dann ein Wert raus. Das heißt der N50-Wert. Und der sagt dann, wie häufig in deinem Haus ein Luftaustausch stattfindet, wenn du die Fenster nicht offen öffnen würdest. Und kein Haus ist vollständig dicht. Klar aber, du hast natürlich recht, die Unterschiede sind enorm. Ein Standardhaus darf so einen N50-Wert von drei haben. Das ist, wenn ich das richtig im Kopf habe, heißt das, dass der komplette Luftinhalt alle drei Stunden einmal getauscht wird durch Undichtigkeiten. Darf einen Wert von drei haben. Wenn du ein Haus hast mit kontrollierter Wohnraumlüftung, KWL, kontrollierter Wohnraumlüftung, dann darf es einen Wert von 1,5 haben, also der Hälfte. Ein Passivhaus darf 0,6 haben, maximal.
0,6?
0,6.
Also 0,6, was heißt das nochmal genau?
Also einen Luftwechsel nur alle drei Stunden oder so wäre das dann. Das müsste ich jetzt umrechnen, das schaffe ich nicht mehr um die Uhrzeit. Aber einfach der Unterschied von drei für ein Standardhaus, 1,5 für ein Haus mit berücksichtigter Lüftungsanlage und 0,6 für was man in einem Passivhaus haben will. Das ist übrigens gar keine Raketenwissenschaft. Dieses Haus hier hat beim ersten Blower-Doortest, den wir gemacht haben, 1,8 erreicht. Also fast diesen 1,5 Wert. Ist damit durchgefallen. Und dann musste der Elektriker nochmal ran und die ganzen Steckdosen in den Außenwänden abdichten. Die waren nämlich nicht dicht. Und damit konnte da Luft aus den... Ja, die Steckdosen müssen in den Außenwänden und die Scheider müssen dicht gemacht werden, damit da nicht die Luft aus den Ziegelwänden rein und raus kann. Und beim zweiten Blower-Doortest haben wir 0,3 erreicht. Also nochmal doppelt so gut, wie man als Passivhaus hätte haben müssen, wenn du so willst. Weil es ist eben keine Raketenwissenschaft, wenn man es richtig macht, kann man da durchaus sehr gute Werte erreichen. Was dann heißt, dass du eben alleine durch ungewollte Luftzirkulation fast keine Energie mehr verlierst. Das aus zwei Gründen toll. Erstens, du verlierst die Energie nicht. Zweitens, warme Luft, die in deine Gebäudehülle wandert, kondensiert dort, weil sie immer wärmer ist als draußen. Und wenn Luft kondensiert, dann schimmelt es irgendwann. Und deswegen ist es nicht gut. Das heißt, man will sowieso immer sehr gute Werte erreichen in dem Bereich. Dann hat man die Problematik, weil man so gute Werte hat, lüftet sich das Haus nicht mehr von selbst. Du kannst mal davon ausgehen, dass der Bestand nicht einen Wert von 3 erreicht, sondern der Bestand erreicht einen Wert von 4 oder 5 oder 6. Also, da zieht es. Weil du so gute Werte erreichen willst und dementsprechend ohne ordentliches Lüften keine gute Luft mehr hast, musst du das mechanisch erledigen, mit so einer kontrollierten Wohnraumlüftung. Und das ist toll. Aus meiner Sicht ist das ganz großes Kino, weil du dich um nichts mehr kümmern musst. Du kannst die Fenster nicht offen stehen lassen, weil du es vergessen hast. Du musst die Fenster nicht aufreißen, musst sie nicht zumachen, musst dich nicht kümmern. Man sagt ja immer, man soll dreimal am Tag Stoßlüften. Hab ich gar keine Zeit für. So oft bin ich gar nicht da manchmal.
Und hier ist eigentlich immer alles frisch.
Und deswegen ist hier immer alles frisch.
Was ich jetzt noch nicht so ganz verstanden habe, vielleicht habe ich ja irgendwas durcheinander gebracht, aber was ist jetzt der Unterschied zwischen deinem Wärmetauscher und diesem Wärmetauscher in diesem Passivhaus?
Es gibt verschiedene Konzepte der kontrollierten Wohnraumlüftung. Es gibt einmal diese Systeme, die die Zuluft zum Haus, die reingeht, auch anwärmen. Und das macht man dann eben mit Hilfe der Luft, die sonst einfach rausgehen würde. Und es gibt Zuluftsysteme, die nichts anwärmen. Wo die kalte Luft oder die frische Luft, wie auch immer man das definieren will, direkt reinkommt. Das ist hier der Fall. In diesem Haus kommt die Luft direkt rein. Da sind so Löcher in der Wand.
Das heißt, wenn es draußen minus 20 Grad ist, dann kommt da auch minus 20 Grad rein?
Genau.
Ist das nicht ein bisschen unangenehm?
Nee.
Warum?
Hätte ich auch nicht geglaubt. Hab ich interessanterweise geglaubt. Ich war dann total fertig, als ich festgestellt habe, dass es tatsächlich nicht zieht. Der Punkt ist, es gibt da zwei Sachen. Einmal muss man dafür sorgen, dass man möglichst viele oder dass man ausreichend Öffnungen hat, die Luft reinlassen. Weil wenn ich genügend Öffnungen habe, dann ist die Menge der Luft, die durch jede Öffnung reingeht, relativ klein. Das heißt, ich kriege dann keinen Zug.
Also richtig kleine Löcher sind das dann?
Nee, das sind keine kleinen Löcher, aber es sind eben auch nicht wenige Löcher. Wenn ich wenige Löcher hätte...
Wie viele sind es denn?
Wir haben jetzt hier unten im Erdgeschoss vier.
Vier. Vier ist nicht wenig.
Nee, vier ist nicht wenig.
Und wie groß sind die jetzt?
Wenig wären zwei.
Handteller groß? Und die gehen direkt von außen rein?
Genau. Hier gehen die direkt durch die Mauer durch rein. Es ist ein Ventil vor. Und dann gibt es so einen Trick, der heißt Coanda-Effekt. Das heißt, das strömende kalte Luft geht nach oben an die Decke.
Wie heißt der? Coanda.
Mit C. Kannst du nachgucken. Steht in der Wikipedia.
Ja, bestimmt.
So.
Steht alles in der Wikipedia.
Genau, da steht alles. Und der Coanda-Effekt sorgt dafür, dass die kalte Luft nach oben gezogen wird an die Decke und sich dann mit der Raumluft vermischt und dann fröhlich runterfällt. Das heißt, du hast…
Kalte Luft steigt nach oben seit wann?
Seit Coanda.
Wer ist denn das? Dieser Coanda. Was heißt Coanda? Also wovon steht das? Ist das eine Person?
Ich glaube, das war ein Physiker, der diesen Effekt dokumentiert hat.
Und wodurch steigt das jetzt auf einmal?
Durch die Strömungsgeschwindigkeiten. Die wird hochgezogen durch die Strömungseffekte, die die Decke erzeugt.
Aber wodurch strömt es denn überhaupt rein, wenn da sogar noch ein Ventil davor ist? Also was bringt die Luft dazu, dass die Decke auf den Boden steigt? Also das ist ja ein Thema, wozu überhaupt ins Haus eindringen.
Genau. Weil die kontrollierte Wohnraumlüftung, also das Gerät, das wir hier haben, einen Unterdruck erzeugt.
Im Haus?
Genau.
Das Haus saugt sozusagen die ganze Zeit Frischluft an.
Wir haben jetzt gerade hier Unterdruck.
Richtig. Das ist schon Schwierigkeit beim Atmen.
Schwierig. Jetzt muss ich das weiß.
So ein Druck auf der Luft.
Verstehe. Okay, das Ding saugt sich sozusagen und dadurch natürlich auch kontrolliert. Das heißt, es wird jetzt nicht reingeblasen, sondern es sackt sich so langsam Frischluft von außen ran.
Genau.
Und dadurch ist der Feuchtigkeitshaushalt des Hauses auch irgendwie gewährleistet?
Vor allen Dingen, es geht erstmal nur um Frischluft. Es geht um Frischluft. Es geht aber auch, ein schöner Nebeneffekt ist, dass eben die warme Luft innen bleibt. Ich ziehe mir nur kalte Luft, trockenere Luft, kältere Luft von außen an. Das heißt, nichts von der warmen Luft und der feuchten Luft kann in die Hülle wandern und dort kondensieren und dort irgendwelche Schwierigkeiten haben.
Ja gut, aber da wird ja immer mehr Luft, wodurch wird dann dieser, ich meine, der Unterdruck wird ja dadurch erzeugt, dass Luft rausgeblasen wird.
Richtig. Und die geht, bevor sie rausgeblasen wird, durch ein Verdampfer von einer Wärmepumpe.
Das heißt, die Wärme bleibt drin.
Genau.
Obwohl die frische Luft sozusagen nicht beheizt wird, mischt sie sich aber sozusagen mit dem Rest. Und da ja die andere Wärme so das Haus nicht wirklich verlässt, nimmt sie diese Wärme dann auch automatisch mit an. Das heißt, obwohl da wirklich kalte Luft reinkommt, kommt sie so in dünnen Dosen, dass es nicht wirklich eine Auswirkung auf die Gesamtwärme hat. Schlussfolgere ich jetzt mal in meinem leidenhaften Betracht.
Ja, es ist ein klein wenig komplizierter. Also es ist schon so, dass kommt kalte Luft rein. Die würde damit die Temperatur senken. Die warme Luft, die aber drin ist, geht halt raus. Bevor sie rausgeht, muss sie durch einen Verdampfer. Der Wärmepumpe zieht die Wärme aus der Luft raus und steckt sie wieder ins Haus rein, nämlich in die Fußbodenheizung.
Das heißt, das ist noch so ein Nebeneffekt. Wir hatten ja vorhin das Beispiel mit dem Passivhaus, was die Frischluft nimmt und aufwärmt, sodass immer warme Luft zugeblasen wird.
Genau, beim Passivhaus ist es eben anders. Da hast du halt keine Löcher in der Wand, sondern du hast Löcher in der Decke, und zwar immer zwei Stück für jeden Raum. Na ja, manchmal wird das auch anders geregelt. Aber sagen wir mal, du hast halt sozusagen immer zwei Löcher. Einmal, wo die Luft eingeblasen wird, und einmal dort, wo sie abgesaugt wird. Häufig ist es so, dass du pro Raum mindestens einen Einblasen zum Einblasen hast, eine Öffnung zum Einblasen. Und abgesaugt wird dann zentral in der Küche und im Bad, so wie hier bei uns auch. Und die Luft trifft sich, die Luft, die reinkommt, und die Luft, die rausgeht, die treffen sich in einem Wärmetausch. Also, die treffen sich nicht wirklich im Sinne von physikalisch. Man will ja nicht, dass die Abluft, die vielleicht geruchsbelastet ist, oder so, du willst ja die Gerüche nicht wieder mit einblasen. Also treffen die sich nicht physikalisch, sondern die treffen sich eben nur, die Wärme da drin, die Energie da drin, die trifft sich in diesem Wärmetauscher. Und dann findet ein Wärmetausch statt, von der Abluft in die Zuluft. Und das mit sehr hohen Wirkungsgraden von über 90, oder inzwischen über 95 Prozent.
Erstaunliche Technologie, das hinterfrag ich gleich nochmal. Aber das heißt, nochmal diesen Überblick zusammenzuschließen, also abzuschließen, im Passivhaus kommt die frische Luft rein und wird dabei sofort erwärmt. In eurem Haus ist es so, die frische Luft kommt wahrscheinlich auch langsamer rein als jetzt bei diesem Passivhaus-Modell, vermute ich mal, oder? Also dadurch, dass ich ja nur durch die...
Ich glaube die Luftvolumen sind etwa dieselben.
Okay, aber es wird angesogen nicht durch einen Motor, sondern einfach dadurch, dass ein Unterdruck erzeugt wird.
Der wird ja durch einen Motor erzeugt.
Ja gut, aber im ganzen Haus sozusagen, das Haus atmet irgendwie ein, also es gibt jetzt nicht irgendwie eine Stelle, an der ein Unterdruck erzeugt wird und dann kommt da die Luft reingeschossen, sondern das ganze Haus wird sozusagen in Unterdruckmodus gebracht und dadurch zieht es, holt es sich sozusagen von außen die Luft rein. Aber die wird eben nicht erwärmt, sondern die Wärme, die das Haus dann fast verlassen würde, wird dann kurz vor dem Verlassen halt auch nochmal abgezogen und dann als Fußbodenheizung wieder reingebracht, was natürlich den schönen Vorteil hat. Ihr habt eine Fußbodenheizung.
Richtig.
Toll. Fußbodenheizung ist super. Schön, ich weiß nicht, also so richtig warm ist der Boden nicht, aber er ist halt auch nicht kalt.
Naja, das ist halt der Trick. Ich meine, das ist halt nicht die Fußbodenheizung deiner Großeltern, die mit einer Vorlauftemperatur von 70 Grad lief, wo einem dann wirklich die Füße geplatzt sind oder so, wenn es draußen kalt wurde, sondern das ist halt so die Fußbodenheizung hier. Die wird halt mal gerade so warm, immer noch unter Körpertemperatur, aber immerhin spülbar warm, wenn es richtig kalt ist draußen.
Das heißt, sie ist nicht wirklich heiß, aber sie ist vor allem nie kalt. Also man hat keinen kalten Boden, sondern man hat immer so einen Boden, der eigentlich so in etwa der eigentlichen Innenraumtemperatur entspricht. Oder?
Guck mal, die Innenraumtemperatur ist so entspannter 21 Grad oder so und ein bisschen 21,6. Aber das empfindest du schon als kalt. Wenn du auf einer Fliese stehst, die 21,6 Grad hast, dann stehst du auf einer kalten Fliese. Nicht auf einer eiskalten Fliese, wie vielleicht bei Oma in der Küche, aber durchaus auf einer kalten Fliese, weil es sich einfach so anfühlt.
Und eure Fliese ist wie warm?
Naja, unsere Fliese dürfte jetzt 22, 23.
Die zwei Grad machen es aus?
Ja, ich meine, das ist halt eine Flächenheizung. Du hast halt zwei, drei Grad mehr auf einer großen Fläche und das macht es dann.
Ja, es ist eine angenehme Wärme. Also bisher kann ich mich hier nicht beklagen.
Seit wir hier mit dieser kontrollierten Wohnraumlüftung leben, muss ich sagen, das war eine der allerbesten Entscheidungen überhaupt beim Hausbau zu sagen, diese Lüftung, von der sie uns ja gerade erzählt haben, ich glaube, so was brauchen wir. Weil das ist der totale Hit. Ich finde das immer toll, immer wieder toll. Und wenn ich mal irgendwo im Urlaub bin und da dann regelmäßig lüften muss oder so und einfach das Raumklima vergleiche oder und den Ärger oder den Aufwand, den man hat mit Lüften oder so, dann will ich das eigentlich nicht mehr haben. Kontrollierte Wohnraumrüstung ist toll, toll, toll.
Jetzt muss ich nochmal hinterfragen. Vielleicht, ich weiß nicht, haben wir das Thema dann auch so langsam ein bisschen eingekreist, aber was ich noch nicht so ganz verstanden habe, ist, wie funktioniert so ein Wärmetauscher eigentlich wirklich? Also wie schafft er es mit so einem hohen Wirkungsgrad, die Wärme aus der einen Luft herauszunehmen und in die andere Luft hinein zu injizieren? Also was macht das Teil? Bist du das verstanden?
Die machen gar nicht viel. Also das ist ja nicht so, dass da, da wird einfach Luft reingesteckt auf der einen Seite und auf der anderen Seite wird auch Luft reingesteckt und der sorgt einfach dafür, dass die Wärme von A nach B wandert, vor dem einen Luftkanal in den anderen Luftkanal. Und letztendlich muss man sich das so vorstellen wie so ganz viele Lamellen, weißt du? So ganz viele, das besteht aus ganz vielen dünnen Lamellen. Da muss halt ein Vorder- und dahinteren Lüfter ein Filter sein, damit sich das Ding nicht zusetzt, ist klar. Und dann ist einfach so, dadurch, dass diese Lamellen angeströmt werden, nehmen sie halt Wärme auf. Und es ist halt auf der einen Seite...
Also Lamellen aus Metall.
Ja, aus Metall, genau. Und auf der einen Seite, musst du halt vorstellen, läuft halt die kalte Luft rein und auf der anderen Seite die warme Luft aus. Und dann gleicht das Metall das natürlich aus.
Verstehe, alles klar. Das heißt, die herausströmende Luft gibt es beim herausströmen ihre Wärme sukzessive an diese Wärmelamellen ab. Und das wird dann eben auf der anderen Seite von der kalten Luft gierig aufgenommen. Oh prima, Wärme und so nehme ich doch gleich mit.
Was nach meinem Verständnis ein bisschen komplizierter sind, sind eben dann die Systeme, die nicht nur die Wärme rübernehmen, sondern die auch noch die Luftfeuchtigkeit rübernehmen können. Das ist dann Wärmerückgewinnung mit Enthalpy-Rückgewinnung, oder wie man das ausspricht. Das heißt dann, dass du auch noch die Luftfeuchtigkeit nicht, die dir nicht verloren geht, was natürlich gerade im Winter von Vorteil ist.
Winter ist ja eigentlich immer das, wovon man so ein bisschen ausgeht. Draußen ist es bitterkalt, wie mache ich das in meinem Haus, obwohl ich da jetzt nicht so viel Energie reinpumpe. Das ist natürlich ganz logisch. Klar, wenn ich mich gut irgendwie abdichte, dann bin ich da schon mal vorgefallen, dass die Wärme rauskommt. Aber wie ist das, wenn es jetzt draußen scheiße heiß ist? Bietet dann euer Hausmodell da auch Vorteile?
Nein, wir haben also keine Kühlung.
Bei einem gut isoliertes Haus hält ja dann die Wärme auch ordentlich drinnen. Wenn es dann hier durch die großen Fensterflächen reinballert und sich das hier aufheizt, zwangsläufig, müsste man einfach auch nur die Türen aufmachen, oder?
Nein, wir haben das schicke Feature, und das ist eine rechts unten Variante, ist der Außengalusin überall.
Ah, okay, alles klar, ihr schaltet sozusagen einfach die Sonneneinstrahlung ab, die Sonne aus.
Genau, du musst dann beschatten. Du fährst dann deine Außengalusin nur so ein bisschen hoch, dann wird es schön hell, aber eben die volle Knalle kommt nicht rein. Und dann kannst du hier wirklich lange noch bei sehr angenehmen Temperaturen sitzen. Also ich habe das im letzten Sommer gesehen, und gerade so ein Ziegelhaus hält ja die Wärme sehr effektiv draußen. Und da hast du echt noch wochenlang schön deine 21, 22, 23 Grad, während alles andere schon echt. Das ist schon sehr schick. Man muss eben aufpassen, dass man die Sonne im Wesentlichen draußen lässt, über so Außengalusin oder was man hat. Und dass man auch nicht jetzt irgendwie die Fenster sperrangelweit aufmacht, wenn es gerade draußen brütend warm ist. Weil dann holt man sich die Temperatur über die Luft rein. Aber wenn man die nur so reintrickeln lässt, über die Lüftungsanlage, dann ist das alles kein Problem. Ja, gibt natürlich bessere Varianten. Die rechts unten Variante wäre aktives Kühlen, zum Beispiel auch wieder mit einer Wärmepumpe, in der man zum Beispiel durch seine Fußbodenheizung kaltes Wasser laufen lässt. Dass du deine Fußbodenheizung zum Kühlen verwendest, zum aktiven Kühlen.
Fußbodenkühlschrank sozusagen.
Genau, da würdest du... Da muss man dann natürlich auch wieder sehen, ob man das mag. Dann hat man eben vielleicht nicht kalte Fliesen, sondern eiskalte Fliesen, wenn man es halt runterkühlt. Dann kann es dann natürlich kondensieren und so weiter, kann problematisch sein und so weiter und so fort. Aber da gibt es, wenn man das rechts unten Modell wählt, auch Varianten.
Zumindest kann man die Eiswürfel endlich fallen lassen.
Genau, ein Thema, das wir noch nicht hatten, ist halt das Thema der Haustechnik.
Aufgesehen von der Wärmeprobe?
Außer von dem Thema, das wir mal über Wärmetauscher gesprochen haben. Das Thema der Haustechnik ist natürlich auch eine riesengroße Baustelle, wo du Wahlmöglichkeiten hast, unendlich fast im Sinne von. Also du kannst halt mit Ölheizen natürlich immer noch überlegen. Klar, dass das ein Auslaufmodell ist. Du kannst mit Gas heizen, so Gas ist fein, ist sehr umweltfreundlich in Anführungsstrichen. Es gibt keinen, wie heißt das hier, Feinstaub oder so ähnlich. Und solche Sachen mit Gasanschluss oder mit Gastank. Dann kann man mit Holz heizen. Pellets ist das Thema.
Also ihr habt überhaupt gar keine Heizung in dem Sinne?
Die Wärmepumpe macht kontrollierte Wohnraumlüftung und Heizung und Warmwasser.
Aber wo holt sie dann die Energie für heißes Wasser?
Aus der Luft.
Nur aus der Luft?
Aus der Außenluft.
Aus der Außenluft? Im Winter?
Bis zum gewissen Grad. Irgendwann ist natürlich Schluss.
Und ihr habt eine heiße Dusche? Da ist der Podcast schon vorbei.
Kannst du nicht mehr nachlegen. Und übrigens, die Dusche war kalt morgen.
Ich schreib das in meinem Blog.
Nein, nein. Also einmal ist es so, dass selbst wenn man immer sagt, heiß Wasser, heiß Wasser ist ein Klacks, heiß Wasser ist egal. Heiß Wasser ist Kindergarten, das macht gar nichts. Weil wenn du von heiß Wasser redest, redest du von vielleicht 200 Litern, die du auf vielleicht 50 Grad hochdrehst. 200 Liter auf 50 Grad ist gar nichts. Vom Energievolumen her, das du dafür brauchst, das ist Kindergarten, nimmt vergleich dazu, das ganze Haus zu heizen. Das heißt, die Wärmepumpe macht die 50 Grad in einem einstündigen Spaziergang hier von morgens um 5 bis um 6. Und zwar rein aus der Luft, und zwar egal, welche Außentemperatur es hat. Schwierig ist, wenn es richtig bitterkalt wird draußen und die Wärmepumpe dann eben noch das Haus heizen soll. So, dann wird es schwierig. Wenn wir jetzt auf die Anzeige schauen würden, würden wir sehen, dass wir draußen eine Temperatur haben von, ich weiß nicht, 0 Grad, minus 1 Grad, irgendwie sowas. Das heißt, wir haben hier Luft, die strömt rein mit 0 Grad. So, und die verlässt die Wärmepumpe mit minus 6 Grad.
Das heißt, er holt auch noch aus kalter Luft Wärme.
Richtig.
Kalt ist ja relativ, solange da noch Kelvin drin sind, ist ja was zu holen.
Völlig richtig. 0 Grad sind 275, 276 Grad Kelvin. Aber es sind über 270 Grad Kelvin, da ist jede Menge Energie drin. Und das Coole an einer Wärmepumpe, also an einer Kano-Maschine, ist halt, dass die würde auch noch Wärme aus der Luft rausholen, wenn wir minus 100 Grad draußen hätten. Weil es sind ja immer noch 170 Grad Kelvin übrig, oder? Vor dem absoluten Nullpunkt, vor sich nichts mehr bewegt. Weil die Maschine in der Theorie kann die dann immer noch Energie rausholen aus der Außenluft. In der Praxis ist das Ding natürlich längst festgefroren. Aber in der Theorie, wenn sie noch laufen würde...
Befinden wir uns sowieso unter einer Schneedüne. Ja, okay, aber der Gedanke ist schön.
Dann würde das noch funktionieren.
Verstehe. Also eine, ja, jetzt wird mir das gerade erst überhaupt klar. Natürlich, so eine Wärmepumpe pumpt einfach die Wärme aus allem raus, selbst wenn da nur ganz wenig Wärme ist.
Genau, muss dann einfach mehr kommen.
Das heißt, man kann sich eine heiße Dusche bauen, irgendwie aus einem Nullgrad, aus einer Temperatur. Das ist dann wirklich krass. Aber ich meine, das ist natürlich nicht mehr so richtig viel Kelvin, oder? Also auch um so jetzt irgendwie, wenn jetzt irgendwie, angenommen das Haus wäre kalt, also angenommen würde sich keine Wärme hier drin befinden. Wie lange dauert es, wenn jetzt draußen, sagen wir mal jetzt mal, 10 Grad sind, bis es warm ist?
Jaja, ohne Hilfe oder mit Hilfe?
Ohne Hilfe, also nur durch diese Wärmepumpe.
Nur durch die Wärmepumpe. Das dauert sicherlich Tage.
Tage, aber nicht Wochen?
Nein.
Okay, das heißt so nach zwei, drei, vier Tagen ist das Haus einfach warm, ohne dass man irgendeine Energie, außer dem ein bisschen Strom für die Wärmepumpe hinzugefügt hat.
Richtig.
Und die Wärmepumpe selber braucht auch nicht viel Strom.
Na gut, ich habe jetzt so eine kleine winzige Wärmepumpe, weil es ein kleines KfW 60 ausbaut. Es braucht halt nur vier Kilowatt oder so Leistung bei minus, schieß mich tot, Außentemperatur, also bei richtig kalt. Und die Wärmepumpe, die zieht einen Kilowatt pro Stunde. So, die zieht ein KW. Und aus dem ein KW macht sie dann halt, je nachdem, wie gut es ist, zwischen zwei bis vier Kilowatt Heizleistung.
M-hm. Müsste man jetzt alles irgendwie klug zusammenrechnen?
Na ja, bei Wärmepumpen rechnet man von immer gerne mit der sogenannten Jahresarbeitszahl. Das ist der gemittelte Wert über das Jahr. Da ist dann alles drin. Der besonders schlechte Wirkungsgrad einer Luftwärmepumpe im Winter und der besonders gute Wärmegrad einer Luftwärmepumpe im Sommer, wo man sie dann aber doch nur zum Heißmachen des Wassers braucht oder so. Und ein gutes Gerät schafft eine Jahresarbeitszahl von vier heutzutage. Die, die wir hier haben, ist nicht ganz so toll. Die schafft vielleicht drei oder ein bisschen über drei. Aber das ist immer noch ausreichend um den primären Energieaufwand, den du bei der Stromerzeugung hast, wieder ins Positive zu gehen.
Ok, angenommen ist es jetzt alles kalt und ihr wollt jetzt nicht fünf Tage warten, bis die Wohnung sich durch die Wärmepumpe selbst aufgepumpt hat. Was macht man dann? Macht man einfach einen Heizlüfter an?
Macht man einen Heizlüfter an, seinen Kamin, also einen Heizstab, in so einer Wärmepumpe. Gerade in den kleinen sind immer Heizstäbe drin, die im schlimmsten Fall zuschlagen können. Dann dreht sich natürlich der Zähler ganz schön schnell.
Aber immerhin, die Wärme bleibt drin.
Ja gut.
Ist das dann auch noch halbwegs effektiv? Also ist das sozusagen zu vertreten, dann mal mit Strom zu heizen für die kurze Zeit?
Wenn es eine kurze Zeit ist, dann ist das zu vertreten. Da muss man vorsichtig sein, dass man ein Gerät auswählt, das zu dem Haus passt, das man hat. Gibt es auch wieder schöne Standards und Geschichten. Es gibt da etwas, das nennt sich Heizlastberechnung nach DIN EN 12831. Da wirst du dann nämlich gefragt, wie warm du es gerne hättest in deinem Haus. Weil es gibt ja Leute, die werden erst bei 24 Grad richtig glücklich. Und andere Leute sagen, wieso 19 Grad? Das reicht für mich, ich dusch auch morgens kalt. Dann sagst du an, was du gerne hättest und dann rechnet dir jemand aus, was die Leistung ist, die du brauchst für dein Haus. Und was für eine Anlage du brauchst. Und dann kommt da vielleicht raus 4 kW. Also für was weiß ich, für ein durchschnittliches KfW60-Haus vielleicht 3, 4, 5 kW. Und dann suchst du dir eine Wärmepumpe aus oder eine Pelletsheizung oder eine Gasheizung, die das liefern kann bei der kältesten anzunehmenden Außentemperatur. Und wenn sie es nicht ganz schafft und dann noch ein bisschen elektrisch zuheizen muss, solange das nur ein paar Tage sind im Jahr, ist das natürlich kein Problem.
Das heißt, die Heizung in so einem gut gebauten Haus ist eigentlich wirklich nur für den Notfall. Das ist also wirklich für die Ausnahme. Wenn es wirklich jetzt scheiße kalt ist und man muss einfach mal mehr Energie reinpumpen, als man jetzt aus der Außentemperatur rausziehen kann.
Richtig. Auf eine Art. Was wichtig ist, ist, dass man eigentlich davon ausgehen kann, wenn man eine Heizung hat, dass die immer nur mit Teillast läuft. Also wenn dir einer sagt, mein Haus hat eine Heizlast von 4 kW, dann meint er, bei meiner lokalen, durchschnittlichen maximalen Außentemperatur, also z.B. minus 12 Grad für bestimmte Gegenden in Deutschland, ist minus 12, glaube ich, eine Standard-maximale Außentemperatur. So und dann 4 kW. Das heißt aber, ich meine, hier in Hamburg rechnet man, glaube ich, mit minus 12, wenn man die Heizlast ausrechnet, aber hier hat es sehr selten minus 12. Meistens eiern wir so um die 0 Grad rum und dann geht es vielleicht mal bis minus 5 oder so. Aber meistens ist Übergangszeit mit minus 10 und ähnlichen Temperaturen. Das heißt, in der Zeit braucht die Heizung natürlich viel weniger Leistung, also wird viel weniger Leistung benötigt. Und dann geht sie halt entweder ständig an und aus oder sie kann modulieren. Sie kann also ihre Leistung modulieren von dem höchsten gewünschten Niveau bis runter auf Bruchteile davon. Und das ist etwas, wo die meisten Gasheizungen, die du heutzutage kaufst und die heutzutage verbaut werden, völlig unüberdimensioniert sind. Den meisten Leuten wird eine Heizung verkauft, eine Gasheizung verkauft, die überdimensioniert ist, was dann heißt, dass sie ständig ein- und ausgeht. Und wenn es schlimm kommt, heißt das, sie geht mehrmals pro Minute an und aus. Das ist dann das sogenannte Takten, und das geht dann auf die Lebensdauer.
Zieht das dann auch nochmal mehr Energie als nötig, durch das Ein- und Ausschalten?
Das auch.
Gibt es denn jetzt noch... Das heißt, Herz der ganzen Geschichte, hier ist jetzt eigentlich die Wärmepumpe, weil die sozusagen alles macht. Es gibt jetzt keine weitere Heizung bei euch, die irgendwie noch was hinzufügt?
Nein, wir haben hier so eine eierlegende Wollmilchsau.
Die selber heizt?
Genau, die selber heizt, wo der Schaltplan in eine Anleitung kommt und wo man sich dann selber noch ein bisschen reinhängen kann und dran rumbasteln.
Mit Schnittstelle?
Nein, die nicht mit Schnittstelle. Also es gibt Anlagen von, ich glaube, Tecalor und Stiebel Eltron und so, die liefern welche mit Seriella. Es gibt welche von, wie heißen die, Heliothermen, glaube ich. Die haben schon mit Schnittstelle zum DSL und Web-Tralala, wo man sich dann richtig Bontografen anschauen kann und so.
Zum DSL?
Nee, die haben irgendwie Ethernet-Schnittstelle und dann hängst du das an dein DSL und dann spricht das mit dem Hersteller und da kannst du das dann selber wieder über Web-Schnittstelle abrufen und so.
Oh, so mit Firmware-Updates und so.
Ja, da bin ich mir nicht so sicher, ob das mit den Firmware... Das ist etwas, wo man manchmal denkt, das hätte man schon gerne.
Oh, weia.
Also machst du ein Ding auf und guckst es dir an und ich habe jetzt an meiner Anlage ein bisschen rumgepatcht wegen der Warmwassererzeugung, ein bisschen rumoptimiert mit Zeitschaltuhr und so weiter.
Wie rumgepatcht hast du das? Wird dir die Firmware geändert?
Nein, nein, das forget it. Nee, nee, ich hab da einfach... Das Schöne an dem Gerät ist, dass der Schaltplan halt beiliegt. Ja, ja, und dann 220 Volt Patching mit bisschen Konrallelektronik, Zubehör und dann...
Was konnte es dann, was es vorher nicht konnte?
Na, es macht jetzt zum Beispiel Warmwasser nur heiß morgens einmal und den Rest forget it. Und was ich als nächstes machen will, ist, dass ich das noch irgendwie koppel mit der Solarthermie-Anlage, die für Warmwasser da ist, dass er wirklich nur nachheizt, wenn die Solarthermie nichts geliefert hat und so.
Ach so, hast du auch noch einen Solarpanel irgendwie oben drauf?
Ja, haben wir ja drauf genagelt, weil es so lustig war.
Ah, aber nicht, weil es wirklich benötigt ist?
Nicht wirklich. Also Wärmepumpe ist ja auch schon Umweltenergie, kommt ja auch von draußen Solarenergie letztendlich, die Sonne hat die Luft angewärmt und so weiter. Aber Solarthermie macht extrem gute Laune. Also es macht einfach gute Laune.
Also liefert warmes Wasser kein Strom?
Liefert warmes Wasser, kein Strom hier. Und bei so einem Tag wie heute habe ich trotzdem 60 Grad im Tank. Also selbst wenn es minus Grade hat draußen, solange der Himmel blau ist und die Sonne scheint.
Aber keine Gastherme blinkert vor sich hin, kein Öl wird verbrannt, kein Öllasser kommt und tankt hier irgendwie dickes schwarzes Öl in dieses Haus. Das könnt ihr euch alles komplett sparen.
Richtig.
Wie viele Jahre wird das jetzt dauern, bis sich das so finanziell lohnt, wenn man den ganzen Aufwand nicht getrieben hätte? Vergleich.
Ja, lass mich mal überlegen. Ich hatte das mal durchgerechnet. Und es ist immer die Frage, welche Annahmen man trifft. Und ob man jetzt sowas wie eine kontrollierte Wohnraumlüftung sagt, das rechne ich der Wärmepumpe jetzt an, weil ich hätte es mir auch ohne die Wärmepumpe eingebaut oder nicht. Wenn man sich es schön rechnet, dann lohnt es sich vom ersten Tag.
Ach echt? Finanziell? Wenn man sich es schön rechnet, was muss man da alles mit reinrechnen? Der Irakkrieg?
Nee, nee, gar nicht mal. Das ist gar nicht nötig. Du musst nur einfach alles rechnen. Du musst wissen, dass eine Gasheizung auch Strom braucht, für 50 Euro im Jahr locker. Dass eine Gasheizung einen Kamin gebraucht hätte, den man hätte bezahlen müssen. Natürlich die Anschlussleitung hättest du bezahlen müssen. Die kostet mehrere tausend Euro. Ein Kamin kostet ein paar tausend Euro. Der Schornsteinfeger kommt alle zwei Jahre bei einer neuen Brennwerttherme. Ich glaube, noch alle zwei Jahre. Wartung muss man machen. Bei meinem Bruder ist die Gastherme gerade nach, ich glaube, drei Jahren ohne Wartung. Da hat es irgendwas zerrissen. 300 Euro, zack. Also man muss die warten, das ist schon wichtig. Das kostet Geld. Da kommt was zusammen. Der Gasstandardanschluss kostet auch ein paar hundert Euro.
Steigen Gaspreise?
Die musst du gar nicht rechnen. Die musst du gar nicht rechnen. Kannst aber natürlich, kannst dir Gedanken darüber machen, dass es...
Ja, es gibt ja diese schöne Ölpreisbindung, wie es so schön heißt.
Ja, es gibt viel erschreckender. Habe ich gerade eine Pressemitteilung gesehen von irgendwas Offizielem hier in Deutschland. Hab schon wieder vergessen von wem. Wo die meinten, wenn Russland so weitermacht, dann werden die ihr Gas bald selber brauchen.
Weil die nicht genug in die Optimierung der eigenen...
Das habe ich auch gelesen.
Die ganze Wirtschaft verbraucht einfach generell zu viel Energie. Also wahrscheinlich nicht nur die Wirtschaft, sondern auch die Privathäuser. Aber man merkt natürlich an der aufstrehenden Wirtschaft und an ihrem steigenden Luxusbedarf, dass sie so ineffizient mit ihrer eigenen Energie umgehen, dass sie demnächst gar nichts mehr verkaufen können. Das ist natürlich eine böse Nummer. Das ist richtig krass, weil davon lebt eigentlich derzeit Russland im Wesentlichen. Sowohl was ihre politische Macht betrifft, als auch was ihren Divisenhandel betrifft.
Als ich das gesehen habe, das fand ich schon erschreckend. Aber das wird uns auch alle betreffen, ob wir nun mit Gas heizen oder ob wir nicht mit Gas heizen. Weil unsere Stromkraftwerke, die meisten davon, arbeiten mit Gas oder mit Kohle. Das wird uns immer gleich alle treffen.
Wohl dem, der eine Wärmepumpe zu Hause hat und aus seiner kalten Umgebungsluft sich noch eine warme Dusche zusammenpumpen kann. Mit Fußbodenheizung.
Solange wir schön die erneuerbaren Energien ausbauen. Weil sonst Strom kommt nicht aus der Steckdose, sondern aus dem Atomkraftwerk. Ich fahr mal nach Frankreich. Ich war gerade mal kurz in Frankreich, in so einem kleinen Dorf. Da hatten sie alle Einglassscheiben. Geheizt wurde mit Radiatoren und Direktstrom. Eins zu eins schlimmer geht es nicht. Aber französischer Atomstrom ist billig, oder? Da hast du wirklich davor gestanden und gedacht, der muss billig sein, der französische Atomstrom. Sonst könnten die sich das hier nicht leisten, ja?
Ja, und da war es geschehen. Die Aufnahme wurde vorzeitig beendet. Wie das so ist. Dieser Podcast war, naja, nicht unbedingt zu kurzfristig angesetzt, aber definitiv zu spät in der Nacht. Da ist dann dieses kleine Malheur passiert. Ich hoffe, dass euch das Thema trotzdem gefallen hat, auch wenn es komplett aus der Reihe fällt. Bei dem, was hier bei Chaosradio Express in letzter Zeit so lief. Aber so soll es ja auch sein. Das Unerwartete soll stattfinden. Und ja, ich freue mich trotzdem über Kommentare und Kritik auf unserem Blog unter blogchaosradio.ccc.de oder im Wiki oder wo auch immer. Oder ihr schickt uns eine E-Mail at chaosradio.ccc.de. An dieser Stelle noch mal vielen Dank an Ron für die interessanten Ausführungen. Und ja, ich hoffe, ihr bleibt trotzdem dabei bei Chaos Radio Express. Ich sage tschüss und bis bald, bis zum nächsten Mal. Auf Wiedersehen!